some of the features revealed by New
Horizons defied simple explanation one
of the most baffling was a pair of vast
mounds on the surface of Pluto
each topped by a deep depression these
mounds look just like young volcanoes
but how could that be possible on a
planetary surface made mostly from ice
scientists turned to similar looking
features here on earth planetary
geologists like Janey radabaugh call
them shield volcanoes this volcano we're
headed for is called
scale River and it means broad shield in
Icelandic on some ways it's sort of the
eponymous shield volcano we're about to
land on
Schill volcanoes are formed by long
drawn-out eruptions of runny lava and
they're said to resemble the shape of a
warrior shield lying on the ground
this one erupted just nine thousand
years ago can see giant crater right
here summit crater that's typical shield
volcanoes and it's actually pretty deep
right here deeper than I expected
this is quite a young volcano and so you
can still really clearly see that crater
and actually we see the sama crater on
Pluto shields very clearly and that
really kind of makes us really think
they could be a shield volcano just
because of it
rod shape and a summit crater just like
this it's not unusual to find shield
volcanoes on other planets Mars like
Earth is mostly made from rock and it's
home to the monumental volcano Olympus
Mons built up from vast eruptions of hot
runny lava millions of years ago but
lava is melted rock and that's a problem
because Pluto should be too small and
too far from the Sun to have anything
melted the kind of eruptions that make
this shape a volcano are you know
hundreds or thousands of individual
eruptions over time they they erupted
out of the fissure and flow out across
the surface and then they just pile up
on top of each other and continue to
flow out building up a broad shield over
time the same thing has happened on
Pluto it's just the lava that's erupted
from Pluto doesn't look anything like
this it does it's not dark in color it's
not made of basalt instead it's made of
water ice
unlike earth Pluto has a surface of
frozen nitrogen on top of a bedrock and
mantle of solid water ice some of this
water ice must be melting to form
explosive flows of liquid slush that
spew out on to Pluto's surface just like
hot rocky lava does on earth the warm
slush freezes rapidly on the surface
building up to form broad icy shields
just like the rocky shields we find on
earth and Mars
you